i'm so glad to introduce you to makeup
instagram god it's me and chad
hello everyone it is me mean again today
we're gonna do a fun little look
it's a three product face
[Music]
as much as i love makeup and i do wear a
lot of pretty crazy looks
i love a very fresh minimal face too
and usually that is what i gravitate
toward these days
so three product face concealer mascara
and this is a cream blush like this
product is interchangeable you can do it
with
lipstick you can do it with liquid
lipstick i chose this because i love the
texture my skin's feeling a little dry
today so i want something a little bit
creamier
more and more emollient
so the first thing i'm going to do is
concealer
to where i need
it really not a lot because to be honest
i like the look of your real skin
showing through
you can this is a long wearing concealer
so you can kind of sleep a little bit on
your eyelid too if you want to
have it act a little bit like a eyelid
primer
i typically would wear eyelid primer
but since i didn't want to add an
additional product the look
i didn't but you can always use that
i have very oily eyelids though so if
you don't even need eyelid primer then
good for you what's that like so my skin
is concealed
let me go in with my blush now so this
is really the hero
product here it's going to be doing
absolutely everything
it's a little bit on the cheek
i'm also going to do it on the eyes and
i'm also doing it
on the lips what
[Music]
okay so blending when i do blush
these days i like to blend up and the
reason i do this
is because i want to give my face a
lifted look
without even having to use contour so
i'm stippling so i don't i don't want to
wipe away the product and then i'm
stippling
up kind of concentrating really trying
not to bring the color
down into where you would put a contour
so you want to use your blush almost
like it is
a contour product and because i like
really well prepped my skin with
moisturizers
before with the concealer i'm still
getting a nice like hit of glow
this is a nude sticks blush by the way
in nudie's bloom
all over dewy color in the shade poppy
girl so i really want i want this to be
a very
very blushy look obviously i'm only
wearing three products so
it's not a lot of makeup so i think my
my skin can handle my look can handle
a lot of blush
you can even do a little bit on the nose
if you want
and then the eyes
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
take my finger
and create a sheer wash of this color on
the lid i don't want to go
i'm not going to go for anything too
opaque
and then you can really lean into the to
the creasing
because to be honest if you wear a gloss
or you wear something like this and
you're going for this kind of sheer look
it's going to crease it's going to
happen and that's okay
you get this beautiful monochromatic
look going on with what's going on the
cheek what's going on on
the eyes and the lips
looks a little crazy right now but once
i get the when i get the mascara on it
will
it will come together all right
mascara time this one is just by
covergirl
you can use any mascara that you want
but i would say to go pretty generous on
the mascara for this look because you
are again wearing so
little on the eyes and the face and
you're going for
you know a pretty blushy pink eye
mascara is really going to help keep
keep that looking springy and fresh
rather than
veering into like actual pink eye
territory
[Music]
the difference one code
[Music]
here we go three products one makeup
look
boom boom boom
[Music]